I am a visual artist and I make
revolutionary art to propel history
forward and I'm gonna come right out and
tell you something
I don't accept the economic foundation
the social relations or the governing
ideas of America my art contributes to
fundamental change by encouraging an
audience to address big questions from
that perspective social change is hard
but ideas matter tremendously when I say
man artists most people think oh he's a
painter behind me you can see some of
the kind of work that I do imagine a
world without America is a painting but
I work on a range of media including
photography video and performance art a
current project slave rebellion
reenactment is going to be reenacted on
the outskirts of New Orleans this
November in 1989 I had an artwork that
became the center of controversy over
its transgressive the use of the
American flag what is the proper way to
display a US flag is a conceptual work
that encouraged audience participation
consisted of a photo montage that had
text that read what is the proper way to
display a US flag below that were books
that people could write responses to
that question and below that was a flag
that people had the option of standing
on the photo montage consisted of images
of South Korean students burning
American flags holding signs that said
Yankee go home son of a [ __ ] and below
that were flag-draped coffins coming
back from Vietnam people were long and
short answers thousands of people
engaged with the work in a lot of
different languages some of the people
said I'm a German girl if we Germans
would admire our flag as you all do we
would be called Nazis again I think you
do have too much trouble about this flag
I think that the artist should be
returned to his heritage ie the jungles
of Africa and then he can shovel manure
in his artistic way this flag I'm
standing on stands for everything
oppressive in this system the murder of
the Indians and all the oppressed around
the world
including my brother who was shot by a
pig who kicked over his body to quote
make sure the [ __ ] was dead unquote
that pig was wearing the flag Thank You
Dred Scott for this opportunity as a
veteran defending the flag I personally
would never defend your stupid ass you
should be shot u.s. Navy SEAL team as
you can see people had very strong
reactions about the flag then as they do
now there were demonstrations of
veterans in front of the Art Institute
of Chicago and they chanted things like
the flag and the artist hang them both
high voguing images of lynching I
received numerous death threats and bomb
threats were phoned into my school it
was a very dangerous situation later
President Bush called the work
disgraceful which I viewed as a
tremendous honor in Congress outlawed
the work I became part of a Supreme
Court case when I and others defied that
law by burning flags on the steps of the
Capitol that action and the subsequent
legal and political battle led to a
landmark First Amendment decision that
prevented the government from demanding
patriotism be mandatory but let me back
up a bit these people literally wanted
me dead what I would do at this moment
would make a difference this is me at
the exact same moment eight stories
above that crowd it was supposed to be
for a photo shoot that was going to take
place on the steps where the veterans
were at that time and it wouldn't have
been safe for me to be there to say the
least
but it was really important to do that
shoot because while some wanted to kill
me it was also a situation where those
who view the American flag is standing
for everything oppressive in this system
felt that they had a voice and that
voice needed to be amplified the point
is this changing anything whether it's
conventional ideas about u.s. national
symbols traditional thinking challenged
by scientific breakthroughs or out sting
authoritarian president requires a lot
of things it requires courage luck and
also vision and boldness of action but
on luck I have to say that the photo
shoot we did might not have worked out
so well
we laughed after we were out of the area
but the thing is it was worth the risk
because of the stakes that were involved
and in this case the luck led to a
wonderful profound and powerful
situation that was also humorous
thank you
[Applause]